listen like isn't your due date right
around now like I mean yeah I might even
go to labor tonight I was just saying
like do you have a plan in the fit I do
not have a plan if I laugh too hard
though who knows what could happen
anything could happen you need like an
escape plan you need some sort like you
to listen I know I'll be up there in the
car just in case I'm just gonna hold it
in as long as I can you know we had a
couple more weeks good luck with that
good news today I don't know if you've
heard that Julian is not gonna be a
judge in the next season well you know I
actually just read that on my way over
here to the premiere and that makes me
very sad because I thought Julian was
doing a fantastic job and I just love
her and I respect her so much as an
artist and I feel like as a pro she's
someone I kind of strive to be like you
wanting me so I always get words of
advice from her is always so healthy but
she's doing such big things I'm so proud
of her now this might be a silly
question is coming from a guy so be
patient with me
will you be back for Season 22 and time
like how does a soul or is that a
possibility
oh no it's definitely not a possibility
I I always try to look at myself as a
superhero like a superwoman I could do
anything and I can make it back but I'll
probably be in the delivery room like
during the premiere of the show but fall
season will hopefully and come back to
the fall
you